thì mà sản bạn rất là bản chiếc kênh công việc thoại thôi
và bản phẩm dịch vô
Đối với người trẻ thì chúng ta sẽ thấy rằng trong các thủng kênh của cá nhân tốt
thì thấy rằng món người là thích
Nhà sự giúp các thích tên truyền lức sống bạn trên các mềm tạng
Nào dịch vô
Chứ họ lại không thích 1 bản bật chất như những người phó tuần
Mời vì khi mà mua như vậy thì mà người thấy rồi mình phải đi xếp hàng
và điều đó thì không phải người rất là thong
Ví người trẻ là 3 tiếng
Chúng ta đang làm gì có thể ra nóng mà đi xếp hàng để mua một chiếc
Ở trong trong tương lai thì chúng ta sẽ nhìn thấy hình a nghe khác
Vì cũng cóp đẩy là dịch lớn vịt
cũng cóp bản hôn lai
Chúng ta có thể ra nóng thì thống rất cứ nơi đâu
Mà không phải đến chức kỳ hàng
Bà thị giúp cái này
Nếu bạn ở một cơm đúng quay sau xôi hàng lánh
Bà muốn mua bà người xưa lớn
Bà sẽ phải lên thành phố lớn mạng dưới chuyển rất là sao
Để không có thể chứ phải là tựa chứ phải là tựa chứ
Để cho đến mua
Thế thì khi mà sản mạng ra đời
Bà chị cần cần điện thoại thôi
Bà cũng sẽ giáu dịch rồi
Như là người tiếp tệ on lai
Hãy như là sau dịch nấu tư con phíao sản mấy lạm dịch tạ
Để nói nóng khắp được cục phía lơ
Nó sẽ làm cho chứ phía mua bản
Cấp đi rất là nhiều
Bà chúng ta chủ lợn
Chúng ta cho người phó chì nấu dịch nấu tư
Mà vì các công không thể giả phong khai mình bà
Ngay cả hình như nha đồ như nha mà cú cấp
Văn chấp cũng như là các khó bán
Để họ sẽ có tự tình trành công bán mà sau phong